should've done a lot earlier I mean that
they haven't been getting the message
out for quite a while thinking that the
Labour Party was something of the past
and that's always a dangerous thing to
do in politics is to underestimate your
position and I think they're gonna have
to fight very very hard to to get the
populace back on their side
Beck's is gonna be very difficult for
them so that's going to be you know
there's gonna be negatives and hopefully
some positives that come out of that I
should go they go along but you know
political uncertainty in the UK is
probably going to be here to have the
next general election
I think we've got to see what the
Conservatives do really I think they
made a complete hash of the election
instead of focusing on the fact that we
they wanted a clear mandate for brexit
they got all involved in various social
issues which the conservative followers
weren't interested in to be perfectly
honest at that time and it allowed the
Labour Party to to get a hold and to
come up with promises they probably
couldn't keep if they did get into power
but it didn't matter cuz they didn't
think they were going to get into power
so now we were in a situation where
quite quietly jeremy corbyn's gone far
left for the last person he was before
even which is hard to believe but you
know he's making promises and thoughts
are there and he's no doubt attracting
events let you know the electorate
Donald Trump did it in a different way
in America so why can't Jeremy Corbyn do
it here and I think that's the question
that people are asking the stars at the
moment
you
you might try to but I think people look
you know I'm an example of the aging
population if like people still have to
save and have to say for their
retirement and for their future years so
that that's not going to go away the
demographics are such that the
government can't afford to look after us
so we've got to look after ourselves and
so therefore you know in the US and
markets are always going to have a role
to play and therefore capitalism it
within those markets has a role to play
whether you're Labour politician or
conservative politician people have
still got to save and whatever the
Labour Party might say they can't afford
to look after us all forever into the
future
you
well being on an island there's quite an
advantage because you never far away
from the office so you don't have to
travel far to do it and so it allows me
to get involved it's just fun I mean
business is fun and I don't think I'll
ever be tired officially I still get on
the golf course quite a bit but I can
get from the golf course to the office
quite quickly as well so that helps the
last time we had you on the show of
course we were talking about Bristol
sport which is your other big business
activity you've satisfied with things I
mean Bristol rugby club were relegated
last year that can't have been helpful
there was tough but we you know we got
something wrong there but we've we've
learned from that and I think we well
focused to hopefully win the
championship this year that's the aim
and get back into the Premiership and
push on a lot of things are going well
the stadium is well established now it's
it's a profitable business which is
always good to hear the Football Club is
it's got good young players coming up
through and creating value again it's
fun and you know at the end of a
business is fun and that's what you
hunted for